hey leute bevor wir zum eigentlichen
idee kommen gibt es noch eine kurze info
für euch und zwar arbeite ich mit dem
wdr und der redaktion von planet schule
zusammen und mache dafür zehn videos
hier auf meinem youtube kanal für mich
ist das einfach eine sehr coole aktion
und ich freue mich schon auf die
zusammenarbeit und für euch bedeutet das
eigentlich nur dass es jetzt regelmäßig
jeden donnerstag ein video gibt und
keine sorge an den folgen selber ändert
sich natürlich gar nichts die
zusammenarbeit ist wie gesagt mit planet
schule das ist eine website auf der
lehrer videos für ihren unterricht
finden können wenn ich also meine videos
gefallen und wir sie gerne mal mit eurer
klasse sehen würdet dann sprecht mit
euren lehrer darauf wann vielleicht wird
das erfassen
so jetzt auch genug gequatscht viel spaß
mit dem video
hier ist ein interessanter fakt milch
besteht zu fast 90 aus normalem klaren
wasser
neben verschiedenen vitaminen und
milchzucker findet man eigentlich nur
noch fett in der milch warum ist milch
also trotzdem weiß und nicht
durchsichtig und warum ist das so
wichtig welche farbe etwas ab nun die
fragen mit der milch lässt sich recht
einfach beantworten
dort befinden sich sogenannte linie die
das fett vom wasser trennen
sie umschließen die fed teilchen und
sorgen dafür dass das fett in der milch
fein verteilt bleibt fällt jetzt licht
auf das milchglas dann passiert etwas
merkwürdiges die photonen werden
zwischen den fetthaltigen hin und her
reflektiert und zerstreuen dabei in alle
richtungen und in alle möglichen
wellenlänge des sichtbaren lichts wenn
man alle farben sichtbaren spektrums
zusammenaddiert erhält man weißes licht
das licht der sonne erscheint uns auch
weiß ist aber in wahrheit aus vielen
verschiedenen wellenlängen des lichts
zusammengesetzt was bei uns im auge
ankommt wenn wir uns milch ansehen ist
also gar nicht weiß sondern eine
mischung aus allen möglichen farben
das weiß der milch ist eine illusion
aber diese illusion ist wichtig wie wir
unser essen sehen beeinflusst nämlich
wie gut es uns schmeckt und wie viel wir
davon essen
man sagt nicht ohne grund das auge isst
mit welches dieser pizzastücke sich
größer aus nun das linke aber wie ihr
euch sicher denken könnt ist das ein
kleiner optischer trick beide sind
gleich groß und trotzdem beeinflusst die
größe des tellers unser gehirn
viele studien haben zum beispiel
herausgefunden dass man auf kleineren
tellern weniger isst und schneller satt
wird weil wir denken dass wir mehr
gegessen haben und sogar die farbe des
celler spielt beim essen eine rolle
achtet mal darauf wie lecker das
pizzastücke mit den unterschiedlichen
tellern aussieht aber woher kommt das
eigentlich wieso lässt sich unser gehirn
vom aussehen beeindrucken wenn essen
doch nur mit dem geschmack zu tun hat
sydney bradford war gerade einmal zehn
monate alt als er sein augenlicht verlor
sein ganzes leben lang war er blind und
musste sich auf seine anderen sinne
verlassen
bis er im alter von 52 jahren eine
hornhauttransplantation erhielt und auf
einmal wieder sehen konnte nicht lange
nach der op testeten forscher seine
fähigkeiten und dabei fangen sie etwas
merkwürdiges heraus sydney konnte zwar
wunderbar sehen aber ihm fehlte die
möglichkeit das gesehene zu verstehen
er konnte zum beispiel eine uhr am
anderen ende des raumes ablesen oder die
entfernung von objekten abschätzen aber
er verstand keine räumlichkeit auf
zweidimensionalen ebene wie zum beispiel
auf bildern oder dem fernseher und bei
ihm funktionierten die meisten optischen
illusionen nicht er verstand sie einfach
nicht daraus konnten wir lernen das
optische illusion nur funktionieren weil
sie mit den erwartungen des gehirns
spielen
wir sehen im kopf nämlich nie das was
unsere augen sehen ständig hilft uns
unser gehirn das gesehene besser zu
verstehen
zum beispiel beim laufen da ruckelt
unsere sicht nicht so stark wie sie
eigentlich sollte blinde flecken in der
netzhaut hat eigentlich jeder
aber sie werden vom gehirn einfach
ausgeblendet und eigentlich sieht man
alles durch das auge verkehrt herum
viele solcher dinge fallen einem erst
auf wenn man viel mit einer kamera filmt
und merkt dass man an der kamera alles
einstellen muss und was unser gehirn
alles für uns übernimmt diese
fähigkeiten beruhen auf den erfahrungen
die wir in unserem leben gemacht haben
unser gehirn interpretiert das was
unsere augen sehen verstärkt manche
dinge oder blendet unnötige
informationen auf diese lebenslange
erfahrung ist es die uns sagen dass das
linke stück pizza größer sein muss
einfach weil es auf dem teller mehr
platz einnimmt dass wir wissen dass die
teller gar nicht gleich groß sind hilft
uns dabei auch nicht viel
visuelle wahrnehmung findet nämlich
unterbewusst
jede form der wahrnehmung findet
unterbewusst stadt anders können wir die
flut an reizen und informationen die wir
jede sekunde bekommen gar nicht
verarbeiten irgendetwas muss
ausgefiltert werden
und jetzt kommt die alles entscheidende
frage wenn unsere wahrnehmung in unseren
köpfen stattfindet woher können wir dann
wissen dass wir überhaupt dieselben
dinge sehen wir können uns alle darauf
einigen dass das hier blau ist aber
woher wissen wir dass ich in meinem kopf
gerade nicht dass hier sehen wir alle
können jetzt gerade komplett
unterschiedliche farben sehen und
dennoch reden wir alle über blau finden
das blaue eine schöne farbe ist dass der
himmel und das meer blau sind und geben
unserer wege ohne jemals zu wissen dass
wir komplett unterschiedliche farben
wahrnehmen
physikalisch gesprochen sind farben nur
die wellenlänge oder die frequenz mit
der photonen durch den raum fliegen
und genau das ist das problem sie
entstehen erst in unseren köpfen haben
sind nämlich eigentlich nur eine
illusion
und das merkt man ganz schnell wenn man
versucht einen blinden die farbe gelb zu
erklären
es geht einfach nicht es ist unmöglich
erklärungs lücke ist ein begriff der
philosophie mit dem man dinge bezeichnet
die man einfach nicht erklären kann man
kann zum beispiel alle nur erdenklichen
fakten über licht und wellenlängen und
die retina des auges lernen und
verstehen aber zu beschreiben wie es
sich anfühlt eine farbe zu sehen ist
zumindest mit unserer heutigen sprache
nicht möglich wie beschreibt man schmerz
zu jemandem der nicht schmerz gespürt
hat wie schmeckt schokolade
es ist unmöglich diese erlebnisse mit
worten zu beschreiben wir können diese
dinge höchstens benennen und müssen
darauf hoffen dass unser gegenüber ein
ähnliches konzept in seinem kopf
darunter abgespeichert hat wir können
zwar mit moderner technik messen ob wir
die gleiche wellenlänge des lichts sehen
aber wir können nicht messen wie unser
gehirn diese wellenlänge interpretiert
denn am ende des tages sind wir in
unserem kopf komplett allein und wir
können niemals sagen ob mein blau
dasselbe ist wieder 1live
zumindest beim heutigen stand der
wissenschaft was meint ihr
könnte es einmal möglich sein die
gedanken und gefühle eines menschen
auszulesen und auf jemand anderen zu
überspielen
könnte man sich dann wirklich komplett
in einer anderen person wieder finden
und ihre gedanken und gefühle verstehen
oder während all diese fremden eindrücke
einfach zu viel für einen und man könnte
sie nicht verarbeiten
schreibt mir eure gedanken dazu unten in
die kommentare schon mega gespannt
ansonsten danke fürs zuschauen und bis
nächste woche donnerstag trick herein